what's going on guys welcome to the last
part of the Arun indicator tutorial
video series or mini series within our
stuck indicators in mathematics in
Python what we're going to do in this
video is actually chart this up so if
you don't already have the empty code
for adding this into this charting
application that pretty much it
let's graphs this with the empty area
for us to put any indicator this is the
code down here the link is in the
description and then just take the code
all the way down to the bottom get a
nice little copy there and paste it in
to an empty script and where we will be
doing all of our coding is right here
between these two comments here to start
a new indicator code so now make some
space in there and all we need to do
first is just copy and paste our other
code right the one that we just got done
building this one into there now
obviously we don't need to be printing
out all this it would be a lot of data
to print out so I'm just going to delete
that little print out there so that was
kind of like our just debugging purposes
right yeah let me just squish this up
nicely anywhere ready so now take this
copy it and all the way up to the
definition of the function just take the
entire function copy that come over here
paste it fix the indent so up here it'll
be two indents one two obviously not the
definition part though don't indent that
and we're all set now all we really need
to do is to find this stuff so again
this spits out a rune date aruna up
Aroon down so we just need to do a date
and we'll just call it a you ad right
for a rune up rune down equals room and
then you put whatever the time frame you
want we're gonna use a 24 now lastly all
we have to do now is just plot it up so
let's do a it stood up live and we want
to apply it and actually date will
conflict so we better call that a date
we want to plot a date and then just to
be with the rest of this charting
application here we use something called
SP for starting point it's just so all
of the data points align up because some
data points are using a 50 moving
average some might be using I think the
other ones a 20 moving are 200 moving
average and so on
you can't want everything to line up
nice and pretty so we're gonna use - SP
- SP : so that's our X is the date and
then our Y is a you - SP : and then
we're going to plot that one as a green
line that's grown up right
so ax to dot plot again you wanna plot a
date with a - SP : and then this time
when I'm doing a deep a ringing down -
SP : and then we want to make this writ
a line a red line because it's the
earlier down line finally we're going to
label it so plot y label and this is
going to be an arun 20 that's the time
frame we've chosen and the color of that
label will be white so we can actually
see it on our black background that
should be it so let's go ahead and save
it run it and let's see what we got
wrong here let's no good that must be an
error in the actual pasting of my
function or my script here I don't see
any other ones but I wonder if that came
from here or not let's look so that was
in the RSI one yeah that's a bummer I
liked this code pasting thing but that's
no good if it's doing that to us it
almost looks like it's only doing it in
that one spot man all right let's see
okay that could let me grab it in and I
just want to see if that was the only
spot that did it because that is a
greater than or equal to sign it's doing
that to me on mmm it makes me so hey I
like that it was nice because all the
other code I was posting didn't look
like this it wasn't as good and I love
happy when I found this little thing
where I could post the code but that's
no good surprised no one complained on
that one so now what we need to do them
let me fix that function I'm just going
to copy and paste the RSI function I've
got hopefully that's the only one that
got messed up and maybe I can figure
to fix that so paste huger difference
those run this function or this thing
again darn it all right man it's those
it's the greater-than signs that did it
hmm well that's a huge bummer I'll have
to work on getting that fixed but for
the time being hopefully I'll have that
fixed by the time anybody is watching
these videos anyways so I'm gonna go
ahead and fix the code myself just by
putting a nice copy and paste into here
so I'm gonna pause the video and get
back to this exact point without the
greater than or less than signs being
all messed up alright guys I'm back I
made the necessary edits on that page it
was for whatever reason sometimes
WordPress will do that I'll start
encoding your stuff so hopefully now
it's on there if I ate this page again
it'll mess up so hopefully I won't have
to edit this page again and if I do I'll
have to remember to to fix that stuff
but for now that's back so by the time
you're watching this you won't have that
issue yeah anyway so now let's go ahead
and run this for real and let's plot a
eBay and just in case anybody missed
that whenever you run this it's going to
ask you stock the plot to type it in and
so here's eBay okay so we've got a
decent look at eBay now over the like
you know the last 10 years and so
everything appears to be working right
let's go ahead and plot one more let's
do through Home Depot that uh ok so here
we go
looks like our ruin indicator is indeed
now finally working couple hiccups there
with the code I'm glad I got that fixed
because like whenever I post the code on
WordPress it gives it like especially
all the quotation marks get all messed
up and stuff so I was happy when I found
this too bad that happens but anyway
yeah so anyway that's the aruna
indicator we're all set there with that
one so that's going to conclude the room
indicator tutorial mini-series and our
python mathematics and stock indicator
series as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support in the
subscriptions and until neck
stern